what's been
the darkest place you've ever gone in
your mind
you wrote that down in my mind in your
mind do you ever consider suicide
i didn't write that okay have you
considered it
in the distance yeah i've distantly
thought about it um
you know
about four months ago
i was in a really bad place
i was naked
in a hotel room
in arizona i hadn't eaten
in like almost a week i hadn't slept in
over a week i haven't slept you know
and i thought i was dying i i was
coughing up blood and um i
was waiting to go into a
outpatient
psychologist place you know i mean in
arizona i literally thought i was dying
so recently i was in a very dark place
how much was that connected to losing
your father how much was that connected
to uh
rehab
and
that kind of stuff
alcohol drugs all the same thing dude
it's all the same thing man it's it's um
it's all from my childhood right the
reason why i do stand up is because of
my childhood
the hating yourself or like being
self-critical that has to do with your
childhood yes so the drugs and drinking
is childhood childhood it's all about
survival and protecting your heart
you know and there are a way there are
ways that i did that as a kid like um
using
humor as a defense mechanism um
and also avoidance of all emotions you
know i mean because i just want to feel
and i'm a the reason why comedy is so
good
the reason why i was able to survive in
comedy is because
i can withstand
a lot of [ __ ] and pain
you know i mean like physic like
physical emotional spiritual pain
i'm i can absorb it right but now what's
happened
you know later in life
is i'm unwilling to do that
i'm unwilling to absorb it i'm unwilling
to carry this weight around with me
and um
it'll kill me so i am doing everything i
can
to free myself of all this baggage okay
so how
you're naked in arizona in a hotel room
face down or face up or on the side or
what's your favorite uh when you go to a
dark place
on the floor on the bed or so what
happened was a
shower a fetal position okay i don't lay
on my stomach that's weird like like i'm
not doing like a downward dog a yoga
position or anything like that no i'm
like
i'm on the bed on the floor no what
happened was
so i had to relapse so i was doing
drinking
all night long what was the first
relapse what what is the thing the first
thing you did just drank what wine
no i took an edible
yeah and that opened the door to
drinking
yeah and the combination is not good for
me um
and i do the
excess of the amount isn't that good for
me i just can't stop and i do it 24
hours a day are you alone
well no i was living with kalila no i
mean at that moment when you do the
edibles i was alone no i took a flight
because i was shooting
magnum i'm on a show called magnum pi
so i was flying to hawaii
so i bought
edibles and then on right before i was
gonna get on the plane
i looked at my girlfriend and said i'm
gonna relapse
i'll send you you know i knew
so i got on the plane i took it
and then
literally the last the next
three months were like a blur
why'd you know what what will give you
the sense that you're gonna relapse
there was a couple of things that
happened in my life that
um
were very shocking to me and um
i
i just and i wasn't going to meetings
and i you know it's the same old story
you know i was not connected to my
sobriety brothers and sisters and i was
drifting away and i um and something in
your mind it was just i just the pain
was too much so i did it and then so
what happened was
now two and a half months in three
months in i
i started coughing up
chunks of blood
right so i was because i've been a
smoker
since i was 17 years old right and i was
smoking so much weed and cigarettes i
would just cough up blood
but then simultaneously what happened
was
bob saget and louie anderson died
right and that week when i was coughing
up blood
and because of because i knew them both
of them
i just in my head going i'm next because
to me everything happens in threes you
know
you know yeah yeah and i'm like i'm and
i had convinced myself
that i was gonna die and that was on the
precipice of death
and so i
begged
my people to put me into this place in
arizona so
because i knew i knew i needed to go to
a really rigorous psychology program to
get me out of wherever what i was going
through and also i was getting at that
time when i was
um in that hotel room i had not
drank or even smoked a cigarette or
didn't drug in a week i had to wait in
l.a for this bed to open up right
so i was coughing up blood i hadn't
slept and eaten right i was sober but
you know i was in so much pain
and i
slept naked by the door of this hotel
room because i thought it would be
easier for the maid to discover my body
i mean that's how [ __ ] up i was i
don't i was just in this
prison in my mind you know and um
i'm much better now can you give some
insights to how to get out of that place
how you got out of that place
i think getting sober first of all was
very important but that still didn't do
it completely you know what i mean i
still was
convinced that i was
and then going i went to this place and
i did you know this place is a
12 hours a day psychotherapy place where
you do 12 hours of you see therapists
all day long
so it's it's like a 12-hour long podcast
every day
yeah yeah but with professionals and
they call you on your [ __ ]
and they tell you what's real and they
tell you you know i mean you know i'm
going
also dealing with you know my still my
dad still some of these other things
that i you know i mean and um
and the the third thing that
happened was when i got back to la after
that place
i i got my lungs checked out and i got
my um
physical done and you know
ekg my heart all of it and i was
completely fine
you know and i quit smoking i haven't
smoked in almost four months
i've been drank and didn't done drugs
since then too so um you know there's
definitely a complete clarity and i i
have to also admit that
this time around
it's just been completely different
is there still in the distance a fear of
relapse and all that kind of stuff is
that still no
so you feel good
i feel great yeah i feel better than
i've ever felt
even when hardship happens
yeah because it's like i no longer want
to be in that place yeah and also on top
of it it's like
it would be a real shame because i
worked so hard to get to this place in
my life not just in my career
with all of it you know i mean i have so
much to lose i have so many people that
love me
i just don't want
to be there again
you